welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Mookie's adventures in game
disappearance with these stolen
tesseract sets the stage for his
upcoming Disney Plus series which
according to some plot descriptions will
be an adventure through time I think I
figured out how this Loki a sassier more
villainous Loki since you know this
version of him from 2012 was still sore
from being rag-dolled could be able to
travel through said time but could this
journey have already been sneakily
revealed to us by some overlooked clues
in endgame and the Loki series promo
imagery the god of mischief has been the
subject of a number of our wild theories
but this time let us track his delicate
footsteps through the multiverse for
another episode of spoiler warning in
case this admittedly slightly bonkers
theory is true and that ruins everything
okay so Loki's that solo series on
Disney Plus will include six episodes
and directly follow his escape with the
space stone tesseract during the time
heist an Avengers endgame and taking
place in his own separate branch history
from the main MCU events we've also
learned that will apparently show Loki
affecting events throughout history
maybe back in the normal MCU timeline
with some vague concept art depicting
Loki in a 1970s setting and in a recent
rewatch of in-game I spotted what I
argued might be a Loki sighting in the
background of camp Lehi in 1970 I guess
if you cross your eyes a little bit and
just pretend this background extra is
actually Tom Hiddleston so first
question how could Loki time travel the
space stone allows travel throughout
physical spatial distances but not
through time some theories out there
have speculated that the quantum realm
is itself another location or place that
can be accessed with the space stone
alone allowing access to the quantum
tunnel time vortex is inside the quantum
realm without using Pym particles I
don't know about that I think that would
actually nullify some of the logic of
endgame which seemed to suggest that Pym
particles were a critical part of that
equation though that again to be fair in
game does itself frequently nullify its
own time travel logic however it's not
impossible for Loki to get his hands on
Pym particles when he escapes in the
year 2012
like going back to that scene an endgame
even argue stark and cap were under a
lot of pressure to quickly think of a
way to get more Pym particles and the
space stone thus hot back again to 1970
when those two things were in the same
place but one option they didn't
consider in 2012 was to just simply
drive over to San Francisco where Hank
Pym was hanging out probably had plenty
of Pym particles in his supply which
would give them hundreds of more chances
to hop back to past points in time to
snag the space stone so when Loki
escapes let's say he just portals
outside and then the overhears cap start
bickering about their time heist
failures which would give Loki a bit of
an in-game Thanos moment his mother
figured out time travel so what would
Loki's next steps be well think about it
in 2012 the god of mischief was far more
nefarious and power-hungry he had just
had his hands on two Infinity stones the
space stone inside the tesseract and the
mind stone inside the scepter in fact
back in the beginning of infinity war
when ebony mod told Thanos that he was
the first person to wield two stones
that technically wasn't true boo-ki had
to as well just not in their raw stone
form they were encased inside other
things so what if Loki's plan is to
simply follow in the footsteps of his
employer and seek all Infinity stones
but this time keep him for himself to
oust Odin and Thor as the most powerful
deity in the Marvel Universe six stones
six episodes folks it's not too far out
of the question
essentially this Loki series could be a
kind of retelling of Bannos his stone
quest from Vanita Warren endgame but now
with a different tyrant swapped in as a
hero this time a more mischievous
manchild who takes far more hilarious
meetings we might have seen another clue
for this earlier in MCU films remember
Odin's vault previously contained an
imposter right handed Infinity Gauntlet
one that hella pushed over and Ragnarok
calling fake now we have speculated in
the past that gauntlet could have been
from an even earlier infinity stone
quest by Odin maybe made all the same
errors that they no state but just had
this come-to-jesus moment earlier before
going too far but maybe
Loki who is right-handed could use this
gauntlet in his own stone quest which
would be a sort of parody of the super
serious one that they anos went on using
the time travel mechanics of endgame
returning to places in locations where
we knew the Infinity stones were like
camp Lehi and on top of that time highs
- them gain make things way
we're complicated but this time in a
light-hearted way so if the low-key
series is going in this direction it
would actually give them an opportunity
to revisit past MCU moments and settings
that endgame didn't have time for the
in-game screenwriters have revealed
concepts for a scramble for the time
stone in the sanctum sanctorum
booby-trapped with spells and artifacts
we know locate wasn't a huge fan at the
sanctum and Ragnarok this could be a
great way to force them back in there
the writers also talked about visiting
the collectors vault on nowhere where
the reality stone was hidden remember
and visiting Morag when it was still
covered by vast oceans with the temple
the power stone underwater there was
also that Easter Egg spotted an in-game
in which the quantum tunnel device
screen showed the Year 2988 as a past
trip destination 2988 BC was the date of
the first battle of Spartak I'm between
Asgard and Dark Elves and Malachy from
Thor the dark world which featured the
use of the reality stone ether could be
another point in time Loki could return
to a no by you but I would love to see
Loki debate Red Skull and Cormier an
attempt to get the soul stone to phase 1
Marvel villains bemoaning how that thick
purple guy casts him aside I think
Loki's time hobby that venture could
also give a perfect opportunity to
justify the various inconsistencies them
see you passed like what if Loki's
sloppy timeline Medlin is to blame for
every MCU plot hole like why did Bruce
Banner and Rudy suddenly transform into
different people between films one of
the other dates listed on that machine
was 2009 a date that we didn't see
anyone go to an end game but 2009 would
have been right around the time that's
which rubra tween Brodie's and banners
happened in the MCU timeline
maybe looky use of reality stone to bend
reality in some bizarre way and that
could be like episode 4 another weird
thing how did agent Sitwell mention
Stephen strange as someone Hydra knew
about in 2014 when strange didn't become
a practitioner of the mystic arts until
2 years after that
well maybe Loki traded Intel about a
future threat and attempted to get back
the mind stone scepter which would have
been in hydras hands at that point and
that brings us to the loki title card
the el okay and i are all in different
typefaces maybe as a way to reflect a
variety of false projected disguises the
god of mischief always takes but if you
look closely at that el it looks a lot
like the el in the Hulk movie title card
and the calligraphy of the O kind of
matches the sanctum sanctorum designs
the seal of vishanti
the aia bagging
so maybe these varying fonts are clues
of the pats Marvel heroes Loki's gonna
visit back in time and metal with if
only loki could go back in time if these
spiderman homecoming eight years later
plot hole and fix it so that spiderman
never has to leave the MCU that'd be
great
Loki once promised Thanos you will never
be a god and he told his brother in that
scene that the Sun will rise on them
once again perhaps that was a mission
statement a bold vision of an alternate
future in which the Sun rises not on a
victorious Thanos but a victorious Loki
six stones richer the god of mischief
and of his own grateful universe and his
first steps could have been taken in
Avengers endgame leaving behind just
enough clues to make a - exposure where
do you think Loki is headed and what
total conspiracy would you like me to
investigate next comment down below with
your thoughts follow me on instagram
twitter at VA vas and subscribe to new
rock stars for the occasional bash hit
theory on this stuff thank you for
joining me and if you think that extra
in the background isn't like anything
like Loki just wait'll you hear part two
of this theory in which I pose that
everyone at Camp Lehigh is actually Loki
Howard Stark Hank Pym Peggy Carter
Jarvis event Nicole Brown actually you
know her character does drop a reference
to MUNGO JERRY
who probably would not have been the
common pop culture reference as early as
spring 1970 in new jersey oh my god back
to the board I need more yarn
[Music]